Fletcher enabled a Gateway for thousands
of criminals to defraud innocent victims
out of millions of pounds
before it was shut down ice Booth was
constantly growing with 700 new users
registering every week and it was
earning 80 000 pounds per week
Fletcher was leading an extravagant
lifestyle benefiting from the profits
having no care for the misery he was
responsible for
he would often go abroad for long
periods of time and he owned luxury cars
and watches in the UK we have now
arrested 169 individuals and we're
Gathering evidence against them
work is ongoing to identify many more
this was the UK's largest ever proactive
fraud investigation